[Musique]
bonjour à tous on se retrouve pour le
7-8 dossier une émission pour décrypter
une thématique à travers une série de
reportages et pour ce mois de fêtes de
fin d'année nous vous proposons des
idées pour remplir votre lettre au père
noël en ouvrant le dossier des produits
fabriqués à la main en 2016 des yvelines
comptait plus de 18000 sociétés
artisanales dont 44% sont des
entreprises individuelles et 20%
dirigées par des femmes
et justement nous avons rencontré quatre
créatrices qui possèdent chacune leur
entreprise
elle travaille seul avec comme outil
leurs mains fabrique des écharpes en
soie des accessoires en bois ou des sacs
à main et pour commencer prenons le cap
de coignières dans la voilerie atelier
couture
valérie vaillant et maître voilier elle
répare dévoile avec ses mains découverte
de ses secrets avec les arrêts ge
donc là j'ai un client qui m'a apporté
un ba1 génois le génois c'est la plus
grande voile qui assure un bateau à près
de 200 kilomètres des côtes normandes
valérie vial garde un oeil sur l'anr
dans son atelier à coignières cette
maître voilier travail est réparé tous
les types de voile depuis quelques
années on voit apparaître des voiles en
carbone dévoilant pentax et des laminés
donc là ça se casse beaucoup plus
facilement
et là on les répare beaucoup beaucoup
plus il ya des files qui sont
particulier si les fibres avec un petit
peu de paraffine dessus c'est à dire que
quand on coud lui chauffe ça fait faire
fondre la paraffine et sa bouche tout
les trouve ça con n'est qu'une voilà les
étanche
valérie vial comment sa formation à 17
ans dans une voilerie à ouistreham en
normandie
elle débarque ensuite à saint quentin en
yvelines j'ai commencé à arriver ici
j'ai travaillé pour nos doux voilerie
qui est à saint cyr l'école
et puis après j'ai travaillé pour la
base de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines pendant 18 ans en tant que
maître voilier j'ai créé mon post sur la
base de loisirs et puis maintenant ça
fait sept ans que j'ai créé ma propre
entreprise en région parisienne comme il
ya beaucoup de gens qui naviguent que ce
soit en planche à voile ou en kitesurf
ou en bateau ça navigue quand même pas
mal donc j'ai un petit peu de clients
c'est régulier 32 ans d'activités pour
cette normande de coeur et les voiles
n'ont quasiment plus de secret pour elle
elle passe tout entre ses mains comme le
spi le génois ou encore la grande voile
sa machine à coudre pour acolytes
valérie développe au fil des ans un côté
artistique
j'étais beaucoup plus créatrices que
couturière donc du coup j'ai toujours
créé plein de choses toujours des sacs
donc je recycle est énormément les
voiles de bateau tout ce que je pouvais
recyclé jeu recyclés en pochette en sac
en pouffant table son imagination
débordante et éco-responsable l'amène à
créer plusieurs objets originaux
réalisés exclusivement à partir de
voiles recyclées
donc ça peut être des voiles de très
vieilles c'est-à-dire qu'elle voile au
début elle était en coton donc comme
celle ci c'est une voile qui vient de
delisle de loctudy qui en rouge parce
qu'on faisait beaucoup de rouge à
l'époque et du tan tan c'est le marron
foncé autrement voilà notre 6e je
récupère même les vieilles râle un
ghetto je dessine d'abord mon sac et
puis après 20 par rapport à la voile il
faut regarder si la voile est encore
bonne donc on la met à laver dans la
machine à laver
et puis on voit ce qui reste et puis
après on coupe ses morceaux en fonction
de ce qu'on veut comme modèle tout
simplement
après vous avez tout ce qui est planche
à voile alors c'est des couleurs un peu
flashy
parce que les années 70 80 c'était que
des couleurs qu'on voit bien sur l'eau
de très très loin la confection d'un
accessoire représente pas loin de 20
heures de travail pour valérie qui en
vrai passionné n'a de cesse d'innover sa
spécialité le vent peut souffler fort
sur coignières les voiles sont
accessibles à tous
on ne trouve pas une planche tout fait
comme ça dans le commerce avant d'avoir
eu obtenir une planche on sélectionne
autre voie et on assemble et on la colle
et liste installe est un peu comme
obélix l'ébénisterie elle est tombée
dedans quand elle était petite
à 39 ans est plaisir waes travaille le
bois depuis 16 ans et dans les copeaux
j'ai grandi au milieu des meubles et des
dés dans l'atelier de mon papa j'avais
toujours voir si je pouvais pas d un
petit coup de main donc les odeurs le
vois mon papa était aussi antiquaires
donc il y avait toujours des meubles qui
rentrait qui repartaient qui étaient
montés des montées donc c'est vrai que
c'était familier après une formation
d'aménagement d'intérieur en belgique il
y suit un crp d'ébénisterie son activité
principale la commande de particuliers
dans mon ébénisterie outre la
restauration de mobilier jeu
réaliste des meubles sur mesure et je
réalise des créations aussi donc
des meubles que j'ai envie de dessiner
de réaliser ainsi que des objets
décoratifs en bois donc soit en tournage
sur bois soit pareil
les petits meubles petits objets le fait
de produire des choses à la main c'est
un gage de qualité
parce que en fait en tout cas chez moi
c'est pas à part des petites séries
c'est pas de la production de masse donc
moi j'ai à coeur de choisir de bien
choisir mon bois le veinage du bois les
assemblages la façon de le faire
duchesne de l'érable sycomore du
merisier eli s'installe se fournit
principalement dans les pays où les
forêts sont durablement gérées un savoir
faire qu'elle partagea son tour je forme
actuellement un jeune homme qui est avec
moi pour la quatrième année et je les
accueille régulièrement des stagiaires
donc ils sont soit en école de
menuiserie soit en école d'ébénisterie
et puis aussi ponctuellement des
des gens qui sont éventuellement en
reconversion professionnelle dont qui
s'interroge sur le fait de travailler
dans deux mois il y a 6 ans élise
installe son atelier à plaisir mobilier
éléments de décoration ou jouets pour
enfants une activité qui n'a pas fini de
tourner
[Musique]
quoi de mieux que le salon du made in
france à paris pour mettre en avant
l'artisanat des yvelines originaire de
plaisir sandrine delhumeau expose ses
créations des écharpes en soie sous la
bannière de l'association la révolution
du fait main une fabrication manuelle et
artisanale est essentielle pour li
blinoise il ya l'importance du geste
la maîtrise d'un geste la qualité du
travail si la précision modélistes de
formation voilà cinq ans qu'elle produit
des écharpes
une activité qu'elle a débuté par hasard
lorsqu'elle occupé son premier poste
dans une tissuthèque il y avait des
échantillons de soie imprimée qui le
servait à personne qui allait partir à
la poubelle
donc j'ai dit non moi je ne peux pas
laisser partir ça à la poubelle donc je
les ai récupérées et j'ai créé ma
première écharpe
de fil en aiguille elle fabrique
différentes écharpe soit circulaire soit
classique et même des foulards plusieurs
styles de soit utilisé des satins des
crêpes de chine des twin ou encore des
mousselines mon intérêt c'est de
mélanger les différentes soit pour avoir
des effets différents
et pour ne pas avoir un aspect trop
lourd autour du cou donc c'est pour ça
que j'aime bien mélanger les différentes
matières
et c'est dans ce type de salon qu'elle
peut partager sa passion et donner de
précieux conseils
selon la manière dont vous allez place
et les chars autour du cou
couleur on se plaçait différemment il a
par exemple de la lettre comme ceux ci
l'a retourné dans l'autre sens et faire
à chaque fois une écharpe différentes
je trouve ça très intéressant le choix
des matières et l'assemblage pour les
assemblages
voilà les couleurs la matière et les
explications qui m'ont été donnés par la
suite mais voilà c'est l'originalité et
les voilà le fait d'avoir un article
unique que ce soit au salon ou dans son
atelier sandrine passe du temps à poser
sa griffe
elle vient de finir une écharpe
circulaire un temps de fabrication de
près d'une heure petit retour en arrière
pour découvrir ses secrets
je commence donc comme je disais à
brasser les soirs c'est à dire à les
mélanger à trouver quel imprimés va
correspondre à un autre quelle harmonie
de couleurs je vais créer je vais
maintenant les assemblées à la machine
pour démarrer mon panneau alors la
couture anglais c'est une couture double
qui permet de complètement emprisonner
les bords du tissu enfin les cacher les
bords du tissu pour éviter les
effilochage et rendre un résultat plus
beaucoup plus nets et mieux fini après
chaque couture j'écrase d'abord ma
couture d'abord je coupe le bord du
tissu
je repasse une première fois puis une
seconde fois et là maintenant je vais
refaire une deuxième piqûre autour de
cette première pour complètement fermée
six aux machines à coudre fer à repasser
sandrine répète ce mouvement jusqu à
finaliser son écharpe en période de
création elle passe entre huit et dix
heures par jour trois à quatre fois par
semaine dans son atelier à travailler
mais c'est avant tout une passion et un
plaisir de soi
du portefeuille au sac à main ici chaque
pièce est unique
des créations que les visiteurs ont pu
découvrir à la cour des métiers d'art de
versailles une première pour marie
dominique hamonou je présente de la
petite maroquinerie essentiellement à
destination des hommes parce que j'aime
bien de travailler des collections un
peu coloré et je trouve que ça change de
ce qu'on peut trouver actuellement dans
le commerce qui est toujours un peu noir
marron etc
j'ai commencé à beaucoup travailler en
ligne mais là ce que j'aimerais c'est
c'est pas me faire connaître sur
versailles déjà puisque j'habite à
versailles et et puis sur les yvelines
en général un échange avec le public
pour transmettre et partager son savoir
faire
ce fait des démonstrations couture
reprendre scellier donc avec une pince à
coudre et c'est une couture qui se
réalise à la main avec un fils et deux
aiguilles c'est une culture qui est
qui est garanti quasiment à vie très
solide et qui rend qui fait un point
magnifique qu'on ne peut réaliser qu'à
la main une méthode acquise auprès d'un
artisan maroquinier d'hermès et avec un
ca paix sur sa fille c'est chez elle que
la jeune femme met en pratique ses
compétences depuis deux ans découpage
collage
elle réalise environ une quinzaine de
pièces par semaine entièrement à la main
aujourd'hui porte cartes en cuir
bicolore une première couche de teinture
donc là c'est pour finir la tranche en
fait jusque là on voit on voit bien
qu'il ya les deux les deux cuir collé et
donc la tranche elle va signer une
teinture qui qui recouvre les deux est
toujours un peu travailler avec mes
mains c'est à dire que mon père était
très bricoleur il était mécanicien donc
en fait on a toujours un petit peu
bricolé dans la famille donc j'ai
toujours un peu travailler avec mes
mains et quand il ya trois ans je me
suis posé la question d'une reconversion
professionnelle c'est vrai que je me
suis dirigé dans ces voilà quoi un
travail qui s'inscrit également dans une
démarche écologique
la créatrice récupère ses cuirs en
ressourcerie c'est du réemploi donc
scellé cuir qui proviennent de chutes et
de fins de séries de grandes maisons
donc c'est quand même des cuirs de
qualité mais qui sont réemployés qui ne
finissent pas à la peine parce que c'est
leur destination au final donc ça me
permets moi de travailler des cuirs de
qualité et de proposer effectivement des
produits qui sont abordables pour tous
vendre 30 euros pour les plus petites
pièces les sacs peuvent aller jusqu'à
189 euros à l'avenir marie-dominique
soit encore plus développé le sur mesure
un terrain de jeu et de création infinie
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce sept huit dossiers
consacrés aux faits main merci de nous
avoir suivis vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission en replay sur le site internet
ou sur l'application mobile tv 78 on se
retrouve le mois prochain pour ouvrir un
nouveau dossier
[Musique]